there's been a lot of talk recently
about digital currencies and everyone's
got their own ideas of how we should do
it i personally have been on television
multiple times saying the united states
should and will digitize the us dollar
now we have representative lynch coming
out and putting forward the electronic
currency and secure hardware act also
known as the ecash act the idea is to
create digital dollars but use many of
the same aspects of physical cash in a
digital form if we go ahead and we take
a look at what this legislation calls
for what we can see is that first it
directs the secretary of the treasury to
develop and introduce a form of retail
digital dollar called e-cash the whole
idea is that it's peer-to-peer privacy
respecting has no transaction fees and
it's payable to bearer just like
physical cash it also moves forward and
asked to establish an electronic
currency innovation program within the
us treasury to test and evaluate
different forms of secure hardware-based
e-cash
and then as you would expect it goes on
to ask to establish an independent
monetary privacy board to oversee and
monitor the federal government's efforts
to preserve monetary privacy this is
really fascinating because then you get
a special purpose ring fence treasury
overdraft account at the federal reserve
bank of new york ultimately what this
legislation is trying to accomplish is
it's trying to take all the ideas of
physical cash and digitize them but of
course the first thing that people ask
is why is legislation being put forward
to create these digital dollars isn't
this just what a central bank digital
currency does
well not necessarily in the eyes of the
legislation the ecas act it would define
ecash as being legal tender a bearer
instrument interoperable replicating
anonymity and privacy respecting
features of physical cash and it would
promote equity and justice but it's not
necessarily a central bank digital
currency they explicitly call out and
say ecash is not a central bank digital
currency and it is not in competition
with a central bank digital currency
either now this opens up an entire
pandora's box if we go ahead and we take
a look at all the various forms of
digital cash what we can see is that
there's a lot of them there's
cryptocurrencies there's stable coins
there's bank deposit central bank
reserves cbdc's fed accounts or
treasuries and e-cash and what you can
see is that ultimately every single
person who's interested in this idea
has their own way of doing things the
market is going to have to sift through
all these ideas we're going to have to
come to a conclusion as to what the
consensus for digital dollars will be
e-cash is one of many ideas central bank
digital currency is another idea that's
being put forward ultimately i don't
know whether it's going to matter or not
because what we have seen is that the
current versions of digital dollars and
stable coins whether we are talking
about tether usdc or ust about 200
billion dollars in the market the
market's doing just fine using them as
digital dollars hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time